because we could see what's well for
Mike
Ricky no thanks thanks for me can
everyone hear me yeah okay so this is
about six inked a shin zuv graph and you
know the basic object is it's an
undirected graph so it's an undirected
graph on n vertices and we're going to
look at weighted graph so the sum
non-negative weights and you know as you
know grass can be used for personal kind
of data say what that is but the basic
goal is to find a sparse approximation
of a graph which preserves some of its
interesting properties that we are
interested in so you know what we would
like to happen in graphic arts education
is showing the picture you're given a
graph G on n vertices an arbitrary graph
it could be dense academic m squared
edges and you would like to find a
sparse graph H on the same set of
vertices so the same n vertices but
sparse which means that it should have
like say order an order and login or
something like that edges and I'm going
to allow the edges in H to be different
weights from the other than G my only
constraint a tradition be too many of
them and I want H to approximate G and
some like natural well defined sense
which is useful for some application and
you know there are a couple of reasons
for wanting to do this so that the main
practical reason is that psycho form of
compression H is you know it takes much
less storage it's much faster to run
computations on and then there's also
sort of a mathematical reason that if
you can show that you can do this for
all graphs rules for the complete graph
that interesting statement like if you
do so the complete graph you can get an
expander ok so you know the intended
application is as you know as Andrew
told you about this morning it's
something like this you're given some
big draft so I got this picture from the
carving and you want to run some
algorithm on it but it's going to take a
lot of time so instead you do you if you
have a fast sparsa fication algorithm
which preserves whatever essential
property or register then you run that
first it doesn't take long and you get
something very much smaller and then use
you get you run Java no more than you
get
proximate output so so whether or not
you can do this of course depends on
what property you want to approximate
small you mean by Proclamation and one
of the first sort of strong notions of
approximation for which this was shown
to be possible as cut approximation this
was introduced by benkler targa 1996 and
you know andrew talked about supporting
you already find it below 0 to sign it
again so so this is you know relevant if
you're interested in the combinatorial
structure or craft so we say that a
graph H approximate to graph G and for
every cut so that's for every subset s
of the vertices of G which is the same
as the vertices of H so for every cut s
the total weight of edges leaving s is
approximately the same in H energy ok so
you would like to happen as shown in
this picture here and left you have some
cut ng it has a whole bunch of edges
crossing it on the right you have some
you have the same time in H and H s
parts so probably there fewer I just
crossing it but the point is you've
adjusted the weights in a way that the
total weight is about the same for this
cut and you want it to be the same for
all cuts all exponentially maker ok ok
so is you know is this ever possible ok
so here's one example where it's
possible so if the input graph is a
complete graph on n vertices then this
is possible so you take G it has n
squared you know order N squared edges
it's a dense crowd and then it turns out
that a very good sparse approximation
for this graph as far as cuts are
concerned is to take a random be regular
graph or D is a constant like three ok
so the soap a case to be runnin be
regular graph this graph is you know as
a DVD it's very far as a response to the
Greek but now let's you know let's look
at a cut so let's just fix a cut s so
the weights of cuts in the complete
graph are you know they're sort of
trivial it is the product of the sizes
of the two sides if you look at the same
cut in NH it's a random graph the
expectation is about what it should be
scaled by the overhang ok so the density
of edges you know
degrees this has the over infraction the
edges of the complete graph so you
expect the number of edges crossing the
cut to BD over n times the product of
the site right now the amazing thing is
that actually you can show that this all
the time probability for all the current
simultaneous so this this farce graph
somehow has the same God structure as a
complete graph scale python by the
appropriate constant ok and then of
course you know if we were what we want
the clutch want them to be 1 epsilon
close let's say so then you just blow up
all the weights in the in the expander
graph by n over D and then you get that
the ratios of the way it's about cuts on
11 ok so the banker and cargo approved
is like amazing theorem that you can do
this for all grass so given any way to
drop you can randomly sample the edges
according some carefully chosen for
probabilities which depend on the
connectivities which andrew talked about
earlier and you can get so you can't
quite do as well as the expander graph
but you can get n log n over epsilon
square edges you can approximate all
cuts up to 1 plus epsilon and you can do
this in nearly linear time so you're
interested in anything like mint card or
max that or anything like that then you
you know you might as well just do this
first is it as far as cuts are concerned
V&H are the same and this is what small
ok so what I'm going to talk about today
is this different stronger notion of
approximation called spectral
approximation and I mean it's you can
think of it as being motivated by
physical processes I often think of it
is like a physical or consummation so
anyway the central object in this notion
respect to approximation is a laplacian
matrix so it's a matrix associated with
a graph like the identity matrix and for
graph on n nodes it's a it's an n-by-n
symmetric matrix whose rows and columns
or index for the vertices that's given
by B minus ay where do you see the
matrix containing the degrees in a THC
metrics but the more enlightening we
review it in this context is is this
next expression it's a sum of outer
products over the edges of the graph so
the grad G has edges be with weights w
IJ
then the laplacian of the graph is the
sum of laplacian of the edges and the
placement of an edge is a very simple
matrix it has four entries there's ones
on the other diagonal and minus ones on
the off diagonals ok so the passing is
the sum of these outer products which
are ranked on matrices and each one
corresponds to and the thing we are most
interested in but the past in here is a
quadratic form so if I have a function
on diversity of the graph if I have a
vector in RN the quadratic form X
transpose LX it's easy to see is this
the sum of differences squared sum of X
i minus XJ squared over edges IJ and
grow and this is sort of the natural
notion of energy on the graph and it
comes with a bunch of different side and
from this from this identity a couple of
things are sort of immediately clear so
the first is that it's a Latinist other
side of that matrix so this quadratic
home is always non-negative so all
diagonal is it I get it and the other
thing is that a for connected graph the
colonel of the laplacian is exactly
equal to the span of the constant vector
ok so I'm saying that because I'm going
to talk about L inverse in a lot of
places and that's you know it's not
invertible but all the plans have the
same no space all connected laplacian of
the famed l space all run collectors i'm
just going to ignore that dong what L
inverse in a bunch of different place ok
ok so so as I said it's like a natural
notion of energy on crap so here's
here's an example of what the laplacian
quadratic phone books like so i have a
graph here and i have some potential in
the vertices so it's just a vector or
already it assigns numbers between node
and the question quadratic form you know
I just look at the difference in squared
over the edge of the net ok and now the
point is that the reason I said this is
a physical notion as if I if I review
the graph is an electrical circuit in
which each edge was a one-off resistor
and I and I took these numbers to
electric potentials then this this sum
of squares is actually the energy
dissipation of the electrical form ok
similarly if I viewed the edge of the
springs it's the energy
okay so so this encodes some sort of
physical properties of the graph I can
look at a very different kind of test
vector if I look at a 01 test vector so
I just put one then some subset of the
Nortons yours else or it turns out it
only it just it just I only get one for
the edges that go but that that leave
the set of one so if i evaluate the
quadratic from 01 vector as i get cuts
so for any cut ass by a value if i look
at x transpose L X for X the current
post electrical cut I just get the total
weight of a living but it's just a
pretty simple calculation so in addition
to encoding these energy properties it
also as a sub case encodes an entire
construction which is a common broker
fee ok so in the language of the
laplacian what banks are in kharghar
showed is it for every graph g there's
an H the quadrat Laplace incorrect form
is preservative 1 plus minus icon factor
on 01 vector we were one test record ok
and this stronger dose or approximation
introduced by Spielman and tangy 2004 is
I'm going to say that it's approximate
see is this hold for all vectors not
just 01 vector okay so i also want i
actually want to maintain
multiplicatively this energy functional
for all potentials ok and you want to
think of this as just saying two graphs
are electrically equivalent ok so as
electrical circuit circuit the energy
dissipation is the same and they proved
oh yeah and from now on I don't want to
keep writing experience both LX all over
the place i'm going to use this father
cypher a matrix mutation so a less than
B in this lesson just means the
quadratic home is point one Western
quadratic form I guess everybody's okay
with this and yeah and what they proved
is they prove that there's also always
it is so for every g into
we can find the graph inch with n log 28
and edges over epsilon squared and it is
a spectral approximation it's just my
story okay so so why would you why would
you be interested in doing this in the
first place so they're a bunch of
reasons the actual reason why they
studied this and the most compelling
reason is that if this notion
approximation is very useful in solving
linear equations in laplacian okay so
solving linear equations and Laplace
ians is a is very useful in physics or
tip 6 it's if you want to solve an
electrical flow problem with the linear
equation over pasion and it's useful in
solving other differential equation
there it's used water I mean it the
codes were in natural real time so the
point if you if you want to solve
laplacian equations fast using an
iterative method like conjugate gradient
if you want to a precondition to a pass
in what you need is actually exactly
this need a spectral spectral
approximation of the ground ok if you
want a precondition one who questioned
by another it corresponds exactly to
finding this spectral notion inspector
approximations this is what motivated 30
million time and they were interested in
getting really fast out with the for
solving laplacian so if you have a graph
on em edges then you know the fastest
thing you can do is look at all the
edges which is order n time the nice
thing to do if you want to solve FX
equals B is you know n cubed Gauss
elimination and there is a bunch of
other direct methods but all of them
worse than N squared and what's real man
tyne day it is early we use this in a
bunch of other things they came up with
all these things to cover the algorithm
does an M nearly dinnertime I'm poly log
in and then after several refinement
sisters
used to Morgan so you can now solve the
plastic linear equations as fast a sort
okay so this is the main motivation the
second motivation is it's sort of a just
for a mathematical point of view if you
preserve all the eigenvalues you
preserve you preserve additional
properties that are not directly well
not directly preserved by disparate
organic cuts like you can say things
about you know random walk structure
mixing time I think like that at finer
level of use it and sort of the third
reason in retrospect is that even though
spectral approximation is a stronger
condition kind of approximation it's
actually mathematically much more
tractable in some way it's actually it's
almost easier to prove these results
then prove enough okay the cut is gone
and you could prove stronger though okay
okay so let me show you some examples of
again what spectral parts nations look
like so you know here again you have you
have the complete graph then you take a
random diego de Graaff i showed you that
all the cuts are preserved up to 1 plus
Phi Epsilon actually the whole quadratic
form is gone or if you can prove this
and so again a random graph isn't right
approximately craft and the dependence
here again if you want both 1 plus
epsilon approximation you need agree
about one right here's a slightly more
complicated example it's a dumbbell
graph you have to complete craft joined
by single edge and you know the you know
the right approximation for this is to
approximate each of the complete graph
by random viewer your graph and just
approximately behave like that and this
works out because this sparse location
this this type of approximation is a
linear it's a linear property so summer
sports cars is far as fire of the Sun
they just you just break up the graph in
pieces you can handle it this time okay
and this example shows several
interesting things about this problem
namely you know the edge in the middle
is the most important edge in some sense
you can't delete it if you do it it you
disconnect the graph and you don't
on the other hand it also has the lowest
weight and that when is order n factor
less than the weights of the other of
the edges in the in this complete graph
works okay and that somehow because of
edges are compensating for the other
items that were deleted so this example
actually shows that even given an
unweighted graph you often need to have
a weighted graph with widely varying
weights in order to get a spectacle
approximation okay okay so so so what
I'm going to show you is how to how to
do this for a private graph fast and the
proof is essentially going to have like
two parts so in the first part I'm going
to reduce this problem about
approximating graph to a purely linear
algebraic problem which has nothing to
do with crap I mean up with graphs are
very special case and then I'm going to
show you how this linear algebra problem
is solved essentially just immediately
by it is a matrix Chernoff bounds which
joe pass them out a couple of weeks ago
and then i'm going to show you how to do
it quickly and in the end I'm going to
show you how I'm going to talk about a
result of calendar and 11 which shows
you how to do it in one fast and of
screaming algorithm but not dynamic has
andrew dr. world to systemic screaming
more okay so production to linear
algebra so remember that this is what we
wanted to do you give a graph g you want
to find a sparse graph H so that the
class in matrix of H is sandwiched
between G and some constant times G
which i'm going to count them ok anyone
h2b spots right so assume assume for our
society is unweighted everything works
when it's weighted so much unweighted
and i'm there are rely on the fact that
the laplacian is it has a special
structure it's written as a sum of outer
products over the edges right that's the
definition i told you earlier and I'm
gonna I don't want to keep writing Delta
I minus L today so so I'm just so Delta
just a vector with one in position I and
I want to keep writing i'm just going to
write P sub E for the signed incidence
director of an edgy so the plus one in
one of the nodes and minus one
doesn't matter which so passing is the
sum of outer products of incidence of
incidence vectors over the engine
program now i'm going to i want to find
a sparse cafes in approximate see i'm
going to restrict my attention to
weighted sub graphs of g ok when it
sometimes in g is a graph which doesn't
have any edges that are not in g but the
weights of the edges it does have can be
anything can be different so if i have a
weighted sub graph H of G then actually
its laplacian is a weighted sum in the
same outer product ok if it has weight
sob it's some sed EV transpose the point
that only uses the same outer part ok
this is sort of a trivial fact that i'm
saying ok so so now given GD fine sparse
eight so the classrooms are closed I
know that apply scenes are sums of other
products and h is a weighted sum of
outer product so this is you're saying
given a sum of outer parts of incidence
vectors which is my graph G find sparse
scalars to find a sparse re waiting ok
these are the SOB to define age such
that this rebated some approximates the
original song ok so I'm just changing
notation a month aren't done anything
I'm just saying that finding wait for
these other products the same thing as
selecting edges it's what do we so this
is the grass propagating problem now I'm
going to do something that seems
ridiculous so you know I know a lot
about these vectors they're designed
incidence vectors of edges I'm going to
observe that this is a special case of
this much more general problem given any
some of our products which it may have
nothing to do with anything find a
sports set of weights sov so that the
the weighted sum approximately original
song lose kappa fact i just threw
everything I knew about common rhetoric
sort of the packaging ok this is a
purely linear algebra problem and now
i'm going to observe something also very
general but actually very powerful which
is this problem is equivalent to solving
this problem which is a special case in
which the sum of the outer product is
equal to the identity so previously i
had capital v equal to any some BB
transposed one special case is wandering
putri identity and the proof of why this
is equivalent is also sort of very
simple basically if I'm given a bunch of
vectors that don't add up the identity
say the address on capital B I look at
the rescaled vectors capital me to the
minus half times Lisa V okay I just you
know I have some vectors there you know
they defined some ellipsoid the
quadratic form find them whoops or it's
not the sphere I just apply an affine
transformations runner and now I look at
these be freinds those are the rescaled
records they are you know by
construction by construction an oakley
identity okay so some of the prime v
prime transpose is equal to identity I
mean just sort of by construction but
now the point is if I find this farce
approximation of reframe the same the
same weights will also work for me and
the reason is that this positive from
your in ordering is preserved under
multiplication by invertible matrices ok
so a lesson me i can multiply by M on
both sides and here I basically my
brought to the identity and then I x
behalf on both sides I approximately I'm
just placing the generalization of the
fact that if you want a multiplicative
approximation or a number you can scale
everything by a constantly changing ok
ok so this is so this is the core
problem that I want to solve give it a
decomposition of the identity signed us
par set of scalars non-negative such
that this re waiting also for and
geometrically what this problem looks
like is you're an RN you're given M
vectors some visa V and add up the
identity and what that means is that the
second moment in every direction is
equal to one so if I look at any unit
vector u I look at some of you in a part
v squared I just get one and just to
really writing this down language and
what I want is I want to find these
waves sob most of which are zero so
there's parts right M could be anything
but I want to find at most roughly order
n of the non zero which stretch these
vectors around
some way so these are these orange
stretchings of the same vectors and now
I want this thing to be close to the
identity which it just means I want all
the Tigers will be modern kappa we just
means that if i look at the second
moment ellipsoid of this thing i wanted
two principal axes that length between
Water Gap so I want to preserve the
shape on this fear this is a gym you
know it's just something around the
Republic ok so there's any questions
about the statement of this problem ok
ok so this ok so i did that because I'm
you know I'm now going to apply some
very general tools to solve this problem
but actually this reduction give it has
it gives you a very sort of tangible
intuition about what's going on in this
graph specification problem ok so let's
just look at what it does to some actual
graph so consider one example the input
graph of G alright downward slope la
cena to some of the hour prior to the
incident vector is that actually turns
out to already be what I'm going to come
isotropic isotropic just means that the
sum of our products is very there
already turns out to look like a de all
the eigen values are the same so then
when I rescale it by LG in the minus
half in order to make it a sphere
nothing happened i just get the same
thing ok fun but now look at this guy
something very interesting happens in
this graph I take the dumbbell graph so
it's two cleats joined by a single edge
if i look at xcel pasion it's a sum of
our products or some incidence reference
which sort of book like this they have
to you know bunches corresponding to the
the clicks and then they have one vector
that's orthogonal to all the other
vectors just sticking up ok and if i
look at the second moment and web side
of this thing right it's really squashed
ok so it's really big in a bunch of
reaction is really squashing one
directly and the direction in which it
squashed corresponds to the one hand you
can cut ok so the squash directions
correspond to small cuts and now when I
rescale it by the inverse of the
velocity
and turn it into the into the sphere
this one vector get stretched a lot so
what this is doing is it's sort of
identifying what the important vectors
are forming this rescale and the reason
it makes out of sense is because I'm
interested in multiplicative
approximation of the quadratic form so
all directions are equally important if
I have something that's really squashed
I might not see it if I just show up is
noise compared to the rest of the the
directions when I do this rescaling it
reveals the electrons that are critical
like this breakage okay so that's sort
of the intuition okay there's something
even nicer which is let's just look at
what the vectors are photographed right
so for a graph you start off with these
incidents lectures PE which I have a
plus one in minus one then I'm
interested in reducing it to this
approximating the identity problems so I
rescale them by LD the might stop or
I'll use of a basket and now what are
the norms of these v's of these rescaled
records right so it's a norm of LG minus
half B squared and the norm squared is
just a hit or product so I i right I
opened the norm squared again that this
is a quadratic form and inverse of the
laplacian okay and I told you earlier
and it's easy to check with ohms one per
class a lot like that that solving
laplacian weather equations the same
thing as electrical flow so these
numbers are actually equal to the
effective resistances of the edges so
the length of the vector corresponding
to e is equal to the effective
resistance of that end in a crafty and
effective resistance of the ganges
electrical picture you have a graph it's
a it's the potential difference induced
across see and find an item for the unit
current to it okay so this is sort of
very intuitively very satisfying to me
anyway which is that you know you're
interested in getting an electrical
approximation of a graph and the notion
of importance of an edge is also a
strictly electrical motion it's
attractive resistance and yeah and so
this is the intuition I decide about
that higher effective resistance means
more important than this rescaling
exactly sort of reveals anyway so so
that's the graph intuition now let me
just show you how to solve this very
general problem given a big
the identity find the sparse we're
waiting in which just goes for a tidy
and I'm going to solve this in a
randomized way and as I said earlier it
implies the graphs course of gauging
problem and I'm just gonna call the
vectors V sub I because I mean it's more
generality and here I'm just going to
use a matrix turn upon so I'm just going
to do a random sample okay so i have a
bunch of vectors at em I've watched
electors may be much more than Morgan
right I want n log n vectors which are
closely at editing I know that the
average of these vectors is the end I
know the sum of these vectors is the
identity right so I know that on average
day if I pick a random wonder it looks
like midnight so you know just like
their concentration equalities for sums
of independent random numbers there is
unusual recording for some random
matrices and this is one of the you know
the first really strong ones is the
DeRozan and it's exactly it's exactly
this statement if you have a
decomposition of the identity if you
sample the vectors according to the
length squared to take n log n over
epsilon for examples and of course you
rescale them by 1 over the probability
these two matrix make it an unbiased
estimator if you do that then you get
within 1 plus minus epsilon theta so I
mean yeah at this point isn't there more
modern tools it's like a sweet winter
without proper there's also more to
other people that you can get slightly
finer bound what route assaulted but
this is sufficient for okay so so this
gives you an algorithm for as far as the
fine crafts it just says for graph
computer factors instances they can work
yet
oh yeah I'm sorry their eyes missing on
flood yeah this is saying all the
eigenvalues will between 1-4 play okay
so so yeah the Alvin I just compute the
effect of resistances and bacon Morgan
over epsilon squared samples in fact
that so that's an algorithm it's not a
fast algorithm because how am I going to
compute the effective resistance is
right so this this this is something we
did in a paper with dan stillman so so
here's what here that we do you you'll
get observed that this laplacian into
some amount of products and then i'm
going to just define a matrix which has
all of these incidents vectors as its
rose this is assigned edge vertex
incidence matrix it's a transpose of the
matrix that Andrew talk about this
morning and then the laplacian is just
equal to be transposed so that's also
need to check the fact and now the main
observation is that these sampling
probabilities the effect of instances
are actually pairwise distances between
a certain embedding of the vertices of
the graph very much distance is squared
ok so these normally e squared in this
quadratic form and LG of the LG inverse
ok but now I don't B transpose B is
equal to LG so I just throw an extra one
in there you can think of be as the
square root of L and then you know I
just I do some regulation like I get
this very sort of nice identity that the
effective resistance of the of an edge
is the distance between its endpoints
squared in this embedding given by the
incidence matrix times a inverse of the
velocity this is an m-dimensional
embedding the incidence matrix vampire
so this is the main fact that we're
going to use that the yeah the effect of
instance is a squared euclidean distance
and we want these numbers quickly right
so if we want it's there some distances
between vector in n dimensional space we
want to quickly we want we don't want to
solve you know I'm going to quit
something like that so then the point we
only care about distance is when you
only care about you clear in distances
you should do done so much for us right
so I only care about distances between
these actors be ellenbrook still too
high columns will be annoyed right so
I'm just going to apply random
projection q of dimension basically
login and I project all these into some
low dimensional space okay the distances
between calls with qbo inverse and these
are approximately what they should be my
consort let's go and now the point is i
can compute I can oh yeah so so so I do
this and I so the point is I never
explicitly compute P L inverse I just
compute QB QB lenders is a log in by n
matrix it's very small and the point is
i can compute cuba Eleanor's by solving
laplacian linear equations right so the
rows of QB linworth inverse our
solutions to random electrical flow
problems is what they are and at this
point I mean yeah there's that new
widget and other facilities is equated
okay so computing each Rosie takes some
new linear time they log in of them so I
can do everything approximately and a
key point in all of this is that
computing the effective resistance is
very good way up to any constant error
is enough okay you don't need to get
cost you don't even if you want 1 plus
epsilon qualities pacifier you can
compute the resistance up to a factor of
100 and just take 100 times with my sin
is purged fine okay so so so this is the
algorithm right it has two parts you're
given a graph in the first step you come
you compute this random projection of
this embedding by solving ballgame or
passing systems in this and now I showed
you that these numbers are equal to the
affected resistances the second step you
just take n 9 and login or epsilon
squared samples with this particular
number that's it and then there's there
are several improvements of this to do
kudus 11 and things will reduce the
running time so I think this gives you m
log to the fifth or something and now
there's you can get m + + log to the
forest you can get you can get
improvements on this running time by
doing you know basically much better
analysis of this every day okay
so I also want to say that there's a
connection to low-rank approximation
here which has been mentioned many times
in this workshop by Petros and Mike and
others so the point is actually these
numbers these norms these effective is
since is squared they're actually the
leverage course of the incidence matrix
if you know what love is cooled off so
actually the sampling algorithm is
identical to this link squared sampling
algorithm of fries can earn Impala and
rules in racine except now where we want
a low rank rank and approximation of
makers okay so it's not actually more
right and there are two important
differences so one is that this
rescaling things to become the identity
it gives you a multiplicative
approximation instead of an additive
approximation this is what you cannot do
in general because in general unit will
do matrix inversion to do this right and
you can do it here because you can
invert laplacian matrix is quickly okay
and then the reason you can compute
these lovers course quickly which also
you cannot do very quickly in general is
because again because of the parts from
solvents because it comes from trap so
the come the fact that this works has
nothing to do with the graph the fact
that it can be done quickly is
exploiting the properties of graphs
quite a bit okay okay so i just want to
mention that actually if you don't care
about running time you can even remove
this log n factor so there's a
deterministic algorithm your bad sense
given myself which gets four and over
epsilon squared but it's it's MN to the
cube mmm n cubed or something like that
sort so I mean okay special case of this
is the person but a good I mean one
question is can you do it any kind of
reasonable you know what in fact how
much time do
okay so now i'm going to present a
result of calendar and 11 from 2011
which shows you how to do this in one
pass in a streaming algorithm but in the
semi streaming setting which is strictly
weaker than the dynamic setting would
end we talked about this morning so here
I suppose you are given like a really
big draft which you can even store
memory and you're like you're yeah you
don't want to just load it into ram and
you know run the algorithm that I told
you about your slowly getting the edges
in some order so it's a semi screaming
setting so you're getting edges that are
being added to the graph you are not
getting any deletions like what hand we
talked about okay so it's a so you're
getting a sequence of edges and what you
would like to do is maintain aspect
response of fire or the edges you have
seen so far in memory and this should
have size n log n for n log n epsilon
squared it should have small size ok and
you would like to maintain this as the
edges are coming in with small update
time preferably so so you know so this
is what's happening you keep seeing you
you keep getting these edges that you
want to update your response fire H as
you see more emerges in this thing keeps
changing and the constraint of course h
cannot contain too many edges so you
can't just keep adding everything you
have to do we that is once in a while
and you have to do is in some way which
preserves property if this is a spectral
foursquare ok so so there's a naive sort
of way to do this orbit prior to do this
which is ok you keep seeing as it's just
keep adding them page until it gets too
big so suppose you have some threshold
like 10 n log n when H gets to like 20 n
log n you have to do something right you
have to make it smaller ok so so it's ok
you're fine you constructed H now you
wait until it becomes too big you wait
until it becomes like twice is because
you want and call these new edges that
you need to do something with gamma so
you have eight which is a spectral
sports for of G and you have gallon and
you would like to find the spectral
force 4g post camp right which is up
there damn well you could just look at h
plus gamma right that's just just just
adding the edges that you saw but this
is not force it has twice as many as it
should have
it is a 1 plus epsilon approximation of
D plus gamma because this approximate
send those reports measure is linear
okay if you want to reduce its edges you
could just parse a fire it again you
could sparse by this and get a 1 plus
epsilon approximation of that which is 1
plus epsilon squared approximately but
then of course this doesn't work because
if you keep doing this you your error
builds up very quickly and you can
barely do it for any number of steps
okay so this doesn't work so so so
here's the problem we're facebook right
you're given a sparse paragraph d and
you're given some new edges gamma that
you have to take care of them somehow
and you want to construct h prime which
is a sparse choir of g plus gamma
essentially just given H so this is what
we were not able to do it right so so
the main idea that they have this paper
is that you should strengthen you should
strengthen your induction hypothesis you
should notice that you actually have
more than just as far as a fire OG you
actually have a sample from this
effective resistance distribution of you
okay so earlier we proved that you take
a graph and take n log n samples from
its effective resistance distribution
you get a sparse fire so let's assume
that you actually have that right so
this is a strictly stronger thing and
now the goal is given such a sample can
you construct a sample from the
effective resistance distribution of g
plus gamma which will of course be a
sponsor for vehicle skin ok ok so how
would you do this so let me show you a
much simpler sort of toy problem which
is what I don't know I thought of what I
try to understand what was going on here
so suppose suppose you are given a
stream of positive numbers X I ok and at
every at any time you want to maintain a
random sample from the distribution
which pics at index I proportional to X
I ok or the X I seem so far such as
distribution P sub P which is this X i
divided by the sum of the X is all so
far well so I mean there's a very sort
of clear way to do this so suppose at
time T you have a sample from from PT
right capital X right there's a way to
use it to generate
sample from PP + 1 right so you I mean I
think it's called rejection sampling but
I mean basically what you do is very
simple it's in this box so you see this
new number X and P plus 1 this updates
you probability distribution right and
basically you keep X a sample you had
before with probability whatever its
probability is now divided by whatever
its probability was the form and
otherwise you just add the new element
that you at it so I mean this is sort of
i mean you can do this is ok I mean the
proof of why this works is sort of this
tunnel you can view it as conditioning
on picking something with the first to
the first p or the last one something
like that okay so I mean it is a real
clear why this works against sort of
just not really anything okay so so okay
so so this is a way to use a random
sample from some distribution to
generate a random sample from so updated
distribution but i'm using that the
numbers here are positive ok so I'm
crucially using the numbers of positive
the numbers are negative this doesn't
work right the numbers are negative then
I could have the you know the
probability the probability for an
element could increase as time goes by
and then if I've already thrown over
thrown around but I don't work right so
so if you have a bunch of positive
numbers you can do so basically I'm
going to try to do the same thing for
for my resistance that way so I'm going
to rely on two facts about effective
resistances to achieve this okay there
are 25 so the first or two facts about
the sampling process so the first fact
is that the sampling probabilities are
effective resistances right okay so I've
given a sample of H which is a sample
from the resistance distribution of G
the second fact is its forms of finding
a graph preserves effective resistance
so this notion of spectral approximation
that i told you about preserves the
laplacian quadratic form which preserved
effective resistances are this
electrical property that a function of
velocity program huh so it also
preserves effective resistances so this
means i can actually even though i don't
have G with me right now I can read off
I can I can
are out of the effective resistances of
edges in G but just by looking at the
effective resistance of the
corresponding pair and eight okay and
the third thing is the resistances or
monotone decreasing as you add edges to
across okay so far I mean this is
physically very clear if I take a
circuit and add some wires or is it up
so these are the two properties and here
here's approve the true property that's
very simple the resistance is as I told
you a quadratic form in the inverse of
the laplacian matrix and the fact that
i'm using is that if g is less than h in
this part of the thigh definite ordering
then g inverse is bigger than a chat
groups and then ok this implies that if
to laplace in the cost and the effect of
resistances are closed for all edges it
also implies this mod raleys Martin
Luther your principle which is I guess
very well but it just says that if i
look at g plus gamma i add edges to be
the resistances only go down ok ok so
yeah
Agence France question
oh yeah so the precise version of this
is so I'm looking at E is just a pair NH
yeah so I mean the statement is actually
for every pair of nodes the resistance
in G is approximately what it was what
it is in age so that I mean I'm not
actually concerned about what edges are
an H although I will only be applying
this very village yes okay so so now
this is this so called Reese parts of a
Cajun algorithm which which they have
discovered in this paper which is the
following so the input now is H which is
a sample from the resistance
distribution of g and i also i'm going
to keep track of which probabilities the
edges in the sample I'm going to keep
track of which probabilities the edges
in the sample H were picked piece of me
and I have this gamma these new ideas
that I'm getting that I have to figure
out some prefer to do something with
them the output is going to be h prime
which is sample from g plus gamma ok
with probabilities with the next year
Sam will probably be fine so the
algorithm is to stop so one is compute
compute the new resistances so I just
added this gamma right so now for every
edge in H and in gamma compute the
resistance of that edge in h plus gamma
I'm sorry this is B transpose L inverse
piece of me okay but anyway it can be
done in a linear time using diesel buses
look life in solvers and call the same
visa V Prime okay and then do this
rejection sampling thing so look at
every edge that's already in this
process oil right and now keep it with
probability P E prime divided by PE ok
so the updated probably / no problem up
there probably is always lower okay
because it smart
property if you keep it then fine if you
reject it then sample one of the new
edges would be appropriate probability P
prime over the total probability of the
new edges this is just actually what I
told you about numbers in slightly more
generality other reason this works is
the first thing is that the resistance
is an H plus gamma are very close to
this is in deep list because H is points
of high energy okay and the second thing
is that this PP prime over P is always
at most one okay so there is the
sampling probabilities or monotone
decreasing and now it's easy to check
that if I actually have this then either
the probability that a particular edge
is included in this parts of fire is is
this P prime to the correct problem okay
now there are some approximation here
and you should be very careful love them
because the whole point of the previous
thing is that it was not robust to these
repeated approximations and the reason
this works is essentially because we're
allowed much much more slack in
approximating the probabilities and we
weren't approximating the laplacian in
our objective function so I mean the
reason this works is good at every step
we're comparing our graph the age that
we have to some graph G that was not a
long time ago that we don't even we
don't even know about right we're able
to keep this connection between H&G
which we don't have and basically the
reason is that even you know 100
approximate reflective resistances are
enough to are enough to computer 1 plus
epsilon qualities pircifir if you take
enough samples that's for the slackin we
have a lot of slack in the number of
samples i can take a thousand five is
nice and this this is what allows me to
sort of reset their order we stir and
then yeah but because the solvers taking
Morgan time the amortized update time
for edges follow again although the
worst case update time is it bad so
that's that's the streaming algorithm
here is a summary of what I showed you
so the first is this reduction to linear
algebra problem which sort of revealed
this interesting electrical information
about craft the second is just how to
solve this problem using random sampling
which was
no and then how to compute the
resistance quickly using gasoline
mistrust third of this streaming
algorithm and I want to end with with
open questions so there are a lot of
open questions here so when I talk to
people who actually applied this who use
this on actual data they usually have
the following concerns so one is they
would like some kind of locality they
would like some sampling probabilities
that only depend on they would like to
calculate sampling probabilities for an
edge only depending on things that are
somehow near that it I don't even know
what the notion of clearness is but
several people will ask me about this
nobody likes to solve linear equations
just compute resistances also even
though there are theoretically with her
time algorithms for doing it like I
liked yeah I met someone who is applying
that's like grass from the brain and
this was like a major problem actually
solving this video can you do this
without the login and anything faster
than end the fourth right now that I
don't know can you do streaming spectral
partyers with deletions so Andrew talked
about how to do cut sparse virus with
deletions with n log n which is amazing
which is like I mean it's a much harder
thing to do and currently the status of
doing this for spectral is n to the five
third so yeah so clearly what I just
showed you realize very strongly the
fact they're only adding it so I don't
know what what happens if you've got it
to me write this there are good parallel
algorithms for solving linear equations
that have depth m to the one term but
again related to the first point of
computing resistances can you do better
than that and then can do anything for
directed graphs so you can't pass by
directed graph that's known but can you
do anything for great congrats basically
and then can do other things in the
string model like most from spanning
tree
yeah so it doesn't build up because you
so the invariant that you maintain is
that you you maintain samples that are
within some constant of the correct
distribution okay and you can make that
constant kind of big okay and because
you're able to actually get 1 plus
epsilon qualities par so far as in every
step so so it's crucial that you don't
update so these probabilities PE that
I'm passing around right it's critical
that there that there are the actual
probabilities with with respect towards
the edge was sampled with respect no
with respect to which it was sampled in
the whole process so that's actually a
subtle point but that's that's what
makes it work that yeah yeah okay